[Applause]
Chuck let it put it your clinic cut it
it has come to this the wolves are at
the gates all of America's enemies are
banging on my bunker door trying to take
me off the air
well good luck haters I'm not going
anywhere
yeah I am inside a lockdown secure
bunker these walls are packed with steel
concrete and if I've correctly
identified the poop
raccoons I'm more protected than a safe
inside a lockbox inside a childproof
bottle of advil and I have everything I
need down here to keep broadcasting
forever
I got my canned rations my pee jar
satchel and an oil drum a pomade and I'm
gonna make this Apocalypse look good to
let them come and let them get me I have
every conceivable tactical advantage
including my incredible godlike patience
I can wait a long time I'll go to them
[Applause]
[Music]
all my enemies are here
the fight starts now
[Music]
trigger warning
say hi together 12
cool
[Music]
which huh
no collusion man hater let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
so be
[Music]
face yeah imma take you over my shoulder
face
just got real
but our emails
[Music]
and Tifa me
[Applause]
[Music]
denry son what the are you doing
all the enemies protecting the
forgotten man
no you're just making a mess of
everything
you and all your friends now who the
hell is going to clean this up all this
talk has consequences asshole real
consequences
[Applause]
the fight continues good you hit down
here with a real truth lies you want to
help me defeat the globalists and stay
on the inside click and subscribe
and help me defeat them because
following me on my youtube channel makes
you a leader it tracks trust me